Germany center-right CDU is searching
for direction in difficult times that's
according to its proposal likely to be
agreed on by a large majority on
Wednesday the last day of the party
conference it includes a clear rejection
of future tax increases party experts
are also demanding further tightening of
Germany's Asylum law does its tiny nuts
or not this is a national challenge on
the one hand there are the many hundreds
of thousands of people who we want to
integrate into this country who are
willing to integrate and who have good
chances of being able to stay here
without stand-alones and on the other
hand you know there are those who have
received a deportation decree and who we
will also have to send back to their
homeland with renewed vigor that's a
wick feeling listen on Tuesday the party
congress reelected Angela Merkel its
leader she expected an honest result and
she probably sensed it would be
unfavorable and indeed it was her second
worse since assuming the role in two
thousand nimah d while I'm i accept your
choice more than pleased with the result
my heartfelt thanks for your trust her
speech was marked by self-criticism and
sadness after a year of declining
support for her party Mackel warned that
the struggle wasn't over yet when he
founded possibly I cannot promise that
things are going to get easier because
we must do what these times demand of us
silence by that she means her
government's controversial refugee
policy which many in her party are
against mangal said last year's influx
of migrants to Germany must not be
repeated and she reached out to critics
by taking a hard line on a touchstone
party issue that sighs all we show our
faces in interpersonal communication
that plays a big role with us and that's
why the full face veil does not belong
here it should be forbidden wherever
legally possible it does not belong in
our country mrs.facey smooth
one hurdle down one to go Mackel may
have been voted party chair for the
ninth time running but her biggest
challenge awaits when she faces the
electorate in September